(humming noise)
- Well, I gotta say,
I'm incredibly excited
to be a part of your DAO.
I mean, the community
you've built is absolutely--
- Fuck the community.
Your only responsibility
is to get their liquidity on the table.
You got a girlfriend?
- I'm engaged, I'm (clears throat)
my fiancé, Sunmi she's a blockchain dev.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Think about Sunmi.
Name of the game, move the
money from your LP's pocket
into your pocket.
- LP?
- Liquidity Provider.
- Right, but if you can make
your LPs money at the same time
it's advantageous for everyone, correct?
- No.
Number one rule in crypto.
Nobody
I don't care if you're
Su Zhu or Su Lung Tang (ox bone soup).
Nobody knows if the token
will go up, down, sideways,
or in fucking circles.
Least of all us DAO founders.
It's all a fugazi.
You know what fugazi is?
- Fugazi, it's a fake.
- Fugazi, fugazi, it's a wazzy
it's a woozy.
It's fairy dust.
It doesn't exist.
It's never landed.
It is no matter.
It is not on the elemental chart.
It's not fucking real, alright?
- Right
- Stay with me
We don't create shit.
We don't build anything.
- Well, we are building a
decentralized reserve currency.
We are bringing stability into--
- What the fuck even is stability?
From who's perspective?
The US Dollar?
Gold?
Bitcoin?
Your girlfriend's birkin?
Stability, utility, credibility,
just more words to mask
the same old protocol
of "give me your money,
and I promise I'll make you more money,"
maybe.
- Michael, give yourself
a little bit more credit,
it's a bit more complex than that.
I mean most defi 2.0 protocols are--
- Nobody knows how it works.
We just take their garbage coins
and put them in a stew
with other useless coins
and call it a treasury.
Now it's a whole new thing.
The code is all forked from Olympus,
I don't fucking know how it works.
Like I said we don't build anything.
So if you have users
who staked and earned 10,000%
APY in the last few weeks,
he's all fucking happy,
he wants to swap his tokens, liquidate,
take his fucking money and run home.
You don't let him do that.
- No.
'Cause that would make it real!
- Right.
- What do you do?
You get another brilliant idea.
A special idea.
Another situation.
Another staking reward,
to reinvest his earnings.
And he will, every single time,
'cause they're fucking addicted.
And we just keep doing this.
Again and again and again.
Meanwhile, he thinks
he's getting shit rich.
Which he is... on paper.
But you and me,
we're taking home cold hard cash
by dumping our governance
tokens on them, motha fucka.
(laughs)
- Right, right.
That's incredible sir.
Can't tell you how excited I am.
- They don't call me Sifu
for no reason am I right?
- Right right (laughing).
(humming sounds)
- Come on!
(humming intensifies)
- Yes, yes.
(sounds of approval)
(This is definitely not weird)
(more moaning)
Yes, yes, yes.
(that's what she said)
Oh fuck.
(Sifu laughs)
All right, cool.
- Alright cut.
- Let's do it again?
- Let's do it again.
- Alright let's do it again